So it's been some comments on some other [computerphile] videos asking what an Arduino is so we're going to cover. What makes different
[Arduino] z' and how you can get involved in them why they're so good show some little examples and talk about some other
alternatives to the Mainstream Arduino, so
Here I have a [dual] Malev [forum]
2009 this is my first Audrina and that you came in a kit
So it gives you a kit [of] all the components of things so basically
What an Arduino is is a open-source electronics [platform]?
So it allows people who aren't necessarily very knowledgeable electronics like myself
To really easily get involved to make cool things so as a quick example of that here
We have a breadboard basically a solderless circuit, so allows you to just plug things into these slots
We're about to solder [anything], so it's really easy and clean to get involved with Latronnik, so the Audrina has a set pin
So we've got our of analog and power pins and a row [of] digital pins
We've got a couple of wires here just to plug into your [dueño], and then this is a piece of elements
It's for play sound and that's pretty much it [on] the digital pins the Arduino our output digital signals to control
Electronics and on the power and the analog pins output analog signals for output our obviously we're going to plug
The red cable into the [five] volt and the black cable into the ground so these just provide the power
So they're just completing the electrical circuit here. You've got the power pins and some analog pins and over here
You've got your digital pins. Just blue one is our data pin, and this goes in the digital slot nine
It's not as neat yet. So it goes in nine. Okay? So that's now everything plugged in so
We've got the speaker is taking Data from Pin 9 and yard
We know because the program we've written just happens to send Data report [now]. So then looking at the board
We have this red rail. Which is our five volt rail and the blue one which is our ground rail
so that's where the power is coming from we then have this blue cable coming from speaker into the data and
We [have] the ground cable going to the speaker to complete the circuit here
we have the Arduino Ide so audrey [know] is programmed with a
Variation on see a basic Arduino program has a set up and a loop and then there's a lot of different functions
Available to access the things on the board for example here
You've got digital right so that writes something to a digital pin forward tents and purposes it is C
We're going to plug the Ide in to the Audrina so on this one. It's a rather crusty and old usb B
But newer ones use micro usb it's my code, so this will set up the speaker the [plate]
So I'm going to compile it first make sure [there's] no [Emma's]
So Arduino programs are typically called sketches it kind of gets across the idea
That Arduino is made for hobbyists and artists not so much programmers, so that's now compiled at you can see from here
So it's done compiling and we've got nice little output that tells us
What is compiled and how many bytes for used ETC? Okay? Now? I'm going to upload it
So now push it to the Arduino so it's compiling the sketch again
[so] you can see some lights are flashing on here now as it uploads
You [choose]
not all
I'm
very unmusical [II]
Sound so on this file. We've got a
Red Beats and we've got an array [of] notes with each note
We have a tone and the tone is output to the digital pin
And then sense the speaker you can see here pinmode speaker pin output
So the pin that that's poked into is in output mode and we've named a speak of him and in the loop
We just play back the list up there
So we're delaying it by the beats set the tempo
and then we're playing notes if we're not currently playing a note then we delay if we are playing a note then we play the
Note that, we're currently on
Arduino has come quite a ways to start in 2005 when it first started
They didn't realize how big the uptake would be in terms of people customizing accessories, so this pin layout
Has kind of become a fixed form factor, so [we] look at this once this is the new Arduino unit from?
2013 [Odd] so it's got the exact [same] pin layout and it's more or [less] the exact same size
so people have made
Things called shields which are basically accessories that provide other functionality and they plug into the pins on top so you have odd we know
Compatible boards which are similar boards or similar functionality that works to this pin layout [the] whole part forms open-source as many clones that use
the Same Pin Layout
There's many accessories and shields that use the same pin layout so it's con they've kind of inadvertently
Made the next hold where standard there's multiple forms of Arduino compatible so I mean if you look at these two
So these are completely compatible
So they've got the same layout so they're compatible with Arduino shields so she would have [to] cross bronze this layout
but then you can have
things that Arduino compatible
In that they use the same software and use same development environments. This is Diy Arduino called a shrimping it
It's made of a shrimp kit
This does Roughly have the same pin layout but it's not in the same shape so you couldn't plug a shield into this event
Modification, but this does this can be programmed by the [Arduino] [Ide] and uses the Arduino software, so this is still arduino compatible
This is actually based on one of the more popular
Arduino at moment the unit and does all the same stuff. It's just
Much much [cheaper], so [I] [mean] one of these I one of these we have all the components the stuff cost about 60 pound
one of these with all the components
These are costing us about 20 pounder kit 60 pounds. Which is probably what?
[$100] something like that no, but people ripping them off
they're
Kind of there was [a] big there is a big issue with
So these ones they don't mind they encourage this [sort] of thing where someone
Makes a clone a cheaper clone and makes it [open-source] and provides the parts exception don't like that the big problem
They have is chinese companies making Arduino clones calling them Arduino and then selling them for nine Dollars. That's the big issue
They currently have because they don't have the mark of quality these ones
do mean if you look at their duma loath if they're very fond of their
Circuit board arts you get a nice little picture of italy there
And this whole blue PCb thing was kind of trend kind of started by them rather than putting the green
Circuit board covering on they left it blue and they've kind of started to transfer to PCBs the only Arduino boards that allowed to be
Called [Audrey] [nose] are those made by the Arduino foundation [cells], but surely the source
Controller it's not people ripping off and cloning it. They're conservative. It's the Arduino name so it's more of a trademark issue
then a
Technical issue or an integer property issue. They just don't like people they want
people if
you buy a board with Arduino written on if you buy board from Arduino you they want you to know [that] it's quality and it's
Made in italy, and it's got this whole homebrew feel about it. Whereas you don't want to be buying a cheap knockoff
For nine, dollars that's going to break in about a month like how one frequently does
And have that called [nidorino] so to more extreme degree you have the makey makey
So we use one of these in the texting with a [recorder] video
basically what these are are they a really easy way for kids to get on electronics allow you to plug things in and
Make controllers, so they work on [an] electric potential
So floppy you can plug fruit in and touch the fruit and [it'll] trigger a key press
So they using the same microprocessor the Audrina's are
The pin layouts completely different and they don't really act like an Arduino does but they are based on the Arduino [software] and you can
Unlock the full Arduino minute and get more at get more control of it. So these are
Not necessary or drina compatible, but based upon Arduino
So this is the rostra pipe
So this is covered in the earlier video
and
This is kind of taken the Hobby electronic world by storm and as a result a lot p of heard of [raspBerry] [Pi] but not
necessarily Arduino you've [know] Audrina spent a lot longer, so
The key differences between this is this is a full computer this one the next as opposed to the small
Microcontroller of an Arduino and while this does have pins that you can use for
Digital input and output and various other standards and like I squared C in that sort of thing
it doesn't [have] the full range of digital and analog capabilities that the Arduino does so it's not as good for Hobbyist hardware and
Because it is a full blown computer and has a full operating system. It's not as easy to mess around with stuff
so if you wanted to flashing
Led [over] all through Pi you'd have to install [an] operating system on [it]
Enable the output pins write a program for it whereas with an Arduino plug it in upload a program
Plug an led into a slot you're good to go
So I'll do a nose [rose] requires use quite a lot in internet of things hacks like sensors around your house or common everyday items
and
Combine them together to do different functions, so the Arduino is really good Cos
It's really well powerful senses
But it doesn't really have any
Internet Connectivity
So how we've done this previously is
We [attached] the Arduino to a raspberry Pi and then we differ Rows by Wireless adapter
and then we collect data from the internet with rosser Pi I feed it to Audrina which was a
Lot of components, and it had a lot of points of failure
[but] with the new [odd] [Reno's] so the Odd we know you and being one of them
This is kind of a hybrid between the PI and the Arduino uno, or the dhumal over this case
so what you have here is a
linux system on a chip and the A-Team mega Microcontroller
So you've got an Arduino chip and a linux system on one chip and it's also has Wi-Fi
So this is a really neat
Cell you don't need to worry about having two boards, and you don't have to worry about Wi-Fi adapters
I mean the wi-Fi configuration on the rascal [is] a complete pain
It's been the death of more than one hack whereas with this plug it in it makes a wi-Fi [Network]
You connect to the wi-Fi network then goes to a nice configuration page?
[you] tell it which network to connect to and that's just done. It's on the internet
You've got full linux computer running the internet which also has an Arduino [on] [it], and you can program this over Wi-Fi
So you don't use any cables so it's really good for hobbyists and people doing stuff at home
But it's also has very serious uses and usages so for example
there's a project called Drg Satna which is making tiny satellites out of Arduino and their
Cubesat so basically they're to a certain standard, so the tiny little Cube satellites
And they are Fully run by Arduino
So people are launching these into space to do very serious applications
so it's gone from being a fun little hobbyist platform for interactive artists and people making remote-control cars and solar panels and
button games to actually being used in Hobbyist space programs
the standards
fermentation kits come with a light sensor and a motor so it's really easy to rig up things for example like [a]
Solar panel that tracks are some you've got lights inside
You can program it to keep track of the light and follow the light and then the motor would just turn whatever
Assembly you've got to hold your solar panel